- [Instructor] By now
you're likely familiar
with the idea that DNA,
deoxyribonucleic acid,
is the molecular basis of inheritance.
You might also have a sense
that it is somehow
involved with chromosomes.
And in this video, I wanna make
sure we can connect the dots
with all of these concepts that we have
when we come to genetics.
What's a chromosome.
How does it relate to DNA?
How does that relate to genes?
And then how do genes and DNA
relate to proteins or other things?
Well, as you can see in this diagram
from the National Human
Genome Research Institute,
they're showing us a blown up cell.
So this is the outer membrane of the cell
that you see right over here.
And in here, they are showing
us the nucleus of the cell.
And inside the nucleus of
eukaryotes, you have your DNA.
Now, the way that they have shown it,
the DNA all looks like
these Xes over here.
Now, it's important to realize
that DNA isn't always in this
condensed chromosome form.
When DNA replicates,
it is in it's loose or uncondensed form.
When it condenses, maybe in
preparation for say mitosis,
then it takes on an X shape.
But this X actually has two
copies of the same chromosome.
But while they are connected,
consider that to be one chromosome.
But then once they separate,
say during mitosis,
then people would consider
it to be two chromosomes.
Now, if we look at chromosomes
under a microscope,
you might see something like this.
As you notice, they come in pairs.
And this is actually what chromosomes
would look like for the human genome.
You have 23 pairs.
The way we know that
this is a biological male
is by looking right over here.
This short little
chromosome right over here,
that is the Y chromosome.
And you can see each of these pairs
have what are called
homologous chromosomes,
which we've talked about in other videos.
But it's the view that
these two chromosomes
code for the same genes,
but they might have different
versions of the genes on them.
You get one of the homologous
pair from your female parent,
and one of the homologous
pair from your male parent.
And we've gone into some
depth into other videos.
Now, it's hard to see
it at this resolution,
but in this image,
each chromosome has been replicated
and is actually two copies
connected at the centromere.
If we were to spread it out,
it would have that X
shape right over there.
Now, the question is how does
a chromosome relate to DNA?
And you can see it in this
broader diagram right over here.
A chromosome is actually just a very,
very long strand of DNA
that's all wrapped up.
And there some other molecules
and proteins that are involved,
like histones like you
see right over here.
that help package the DNA,
but that's all a chromosome really is.
In the entire human genome,
we have 3.2 billion base pairs in our DNA.
And just as a reminder,
a base pair you can view
as each of the rungs of this ladder.
Now, those 3.2 billion base pairs,
they are divided into these 46 chromosomes
in a complete human genome.
So you're looking at the order
of tens to hundreds of millions
of base pairs per chromosome.
Now you're probably
familiar with this idea
that the genes on the DNA
are actually what code for protein.
And that is indeed the case.
If you have a long strand
of DNA right over here,
not all of it is protein coding,
but you have protein coding genes on it.
And if you look at the
entire human genome,
you're looking at about 20,000
plus protein coding genes,
each of which is made up
an average of about 3000 base pairs,
but it can vary a lot
depending on the gene you're looking at.
And the way that we go from
these protein coding genes,
which are really just sections of the DNA
on these chromosomes, to proteins,
this idea is known as the
central dogma of biology
or oftentimes the central
dogma of molecular biology.
So this is a chain of DNA
in a protein coding gene.
The process of transcription
is what takes us
from one half of this to an mRNA strand,
which you can view as a
cousin molecule of DNA.
Now, messenger RNA in particular,
that then goes to the ribosomes.
It goes outside of the
nucleus of the cell,
goes to the ribosomes.
We talk about this in some
depth in other videos.
And then at the ribosomes,
that information is used to
actually construct proteins
out of amino acids.
And then those proteins,
those amino acids,
will interact with each other
and they'll form a shape of some protein
that is valuable in the human body.
Now, what's interesting
is that even though we most
associate DNA with genes
that code for proteins in this way,
the reality is that only 1-2%
of DNA codes for proteins.
So a natural question would be,
what is the other 98-99% of DNA doing?
And that's actually an
active area of research,
but we have some good ideas.
We know that some of that DNA
helps regulate the coding of other DNA.
What's interesting about the human genome,
or actually the genome of any organism,
is that nearly every
cell in the human body
has this same set of chromosomes,
has all of the information necessary
to code for all of the proteins
that any cell might need.
Exceptions are red blood cells,
which lose their genetic material,
and gametes, sperm, or egg cells,
which have half of the genetic material,
but almost every other cell
has all the genetic material.
But obviously cells are different.
Heart cells are different than neurons,
which are different than skin cells.
So a lot of the other DNA
is part of the regulatory mechanism
of which genes to express,
which genes should be coded into proteins
and which ones should not,
as we have different types of
cells doing different things.
And so this is known as
differential gene expression.
And those parts of the DNA
that aren't coding directly for proteins,
we would call those
regulatory sections of DNA.
Now, there's other stretches of DNA
that instead of producing mRNA,
which then gets translated
into polypeptides,
it could code for other types of RNA,
which we would call functional RNA
because that type of
RNA is directly useful.
It has a function. It's not
just transmitting information.
For example, you have ribosomal RNA,
which can be directly
transcribed from DNA,
and it's used to make up
parts of the ribosome.
You might've seen transfer RNA
when we learned about translation.
They're also involved in the
construction of proteins.
So I will leave you there.
Hopefully this connects the dots
between the idea that most of
your cells in the human body,
and we're talking about
tens of trillions of cells,
have the entire complement
of 3.2 billion base pairs
that are in these 46 chromosomes
that are organized in 23 pairs
that contain these 20,000+ genes,
which only make up 1-2% of the base pairs.
The rest we're still exploring,
but it can be involved in
functional RNA and regulation,
which helps different cells
do different things at different times.